let's talk about what's going on in Hong
Kong because things are still very tense
thousands of people have been protesting
and occupying the streets for months in
parts of the city looked like a war zone
with started out as an outcry over an
extradition bill reignited the
pro-democracy movement that's not
backing down so what exactly is Hong
Kong's ongoing standoff about and where
could it lead there's a lot of history
and background to the current unrest in
Hong Kong but the trigger was a
high-profile murder case that exposed a
legal loophole in 2018 a couple from
Hong Kong went on holiday to Taiwan but
20 year old poon Huw wing never came
home
a month later her 19 year old boyfriend
Chun Tong CAI confessed that he killed
her that's Cham leaving his hotel in
Taiwan with his girlfriend's body
allegedly inside that suitcase
[Music]
chan was arrested back in Hong Kong but
the problem was that Hong Kong's courts
couldn't prosecute him for a murder he
said he committed in Taiwan and
officials in Taiwan said they couldn't
either because there's no extradition
agreement between the two territories
so instead Hong Kong's authorities
charged Chan with money-laundering
because he used his girlfriend's credit
card after she died
Shan ended up serving 19 out of his 29
month jail sentence in Hong Kong but the
question was what to do about the murder
case back in Taiwan so what Hong Kong
lawmakers did was propose a new
extradition bill to allow suspects
accused of serious crimes to face trial
in Hong Kong or Taiwan but also in China
and that rung alarm bells for many
people the Chinese government is often
accused of going after its political
opponents Human Rights Watch says
China's dissidents have been subjected
to show trials force confessions and
even torture there have also been
reports of people disappearing from Hong
Kong and ending up on the mainland
there's a lot of arguments that centers
around the bookseller case which in
years ago.we
bookseller in Hong Kong was being
abducted to mainland China and some of
the cases so these fears justified or
not tell us about concerns that some of
the people in hong kong that they do not
believe in the mainland's legal systems
so that's why protesters have been so
against the extradition bill but there's
a deeper conflict at play here and to
explain that we have to rewind a few
years hong kong was part of china for
centuries
but after winning the first opium war in
the mid eighteen hundreds britain ended
up ruling hong kong for a hundred and
fifty years it never became fully
democratic but hong kong did become a
major business center while the
communist party came into force on
mainland china hong kong await the entir
- the communist army Talan then in 1997
Britain gave Hong Kong back China will
tonight take responsibility for a place
and the people which matter greatly to
us all but the two sides agreed that
Hong Kong could keep some
for 50 years until it fully reunites
with the mainland in 2047
so to soften the transition they came up
with a principle called one country two
systems'
it means Hong Kong belongs to Communist
China but gets to run its own economy
police force justice system and it's
allowed some democratic reforms we're
learning that in Hong Kong we trap
you know speech press assembly that we
can check on the government whenever
they do something that are not for the
people but China controls the bigger
stuff like the military foreign affairs
and to some extent Hong Kong's political
system for example Hong Kong's top
political leader the chief executive is
selected by a closed committee and
approved by China Hong Kong's lawmaking
body called the Legislative Council is
also pretty unique 35 of its 70 seats
are for elected politicians from both
the pro-democracy and pro-china camps
but the other half is reserved for
different sectors in Hong Kong like
education health tourism or finance the
issue with that system though is that
many of those sectors have business ties
with the mainland so critics say that
makes the pro-china bloc bigger and
leads to more pro-china laws being
pushed through the Legislative Council
those law and he china will always make
the case for democracy and how he cannot
be absorbed by the world so there's been
this constant back and forth between
those who feel part of china and those
who want to pull away those who want
more democracy and those who don't and
from time to time the tension boils over
over the years Hong Kongers have taken
to the streets to protest against all
sorts of laws they've seen as stepping
on their freedoms in 2014 the
student-led umbrella movement shut down
the city for three
[Music]
but this year as demonstrations are
different
these are the largest protests Hong Kong
has ever seen they've gone on for more
than six months and this time the city's
pro-democracy movement has the support
of many more groups including teachers
and financial sector workers there's far
more violence - tear gas rocks Molotov
cocktails and even live bullets has
refused
so far one person has died dozens have
been injured and hundreds have been
charged with protest related offenses
police and protesters blame each other
for the increasingly intense
confrontations parts of the city have
been paralyzed and badly damaged like
transport systems and even the
Legislative Council building and there's
no sign of either side backing down MIDI
poet Olga Han light
yeah unions Hugo oh yeah it's on the toy
soul cow how you see man white thing
protesters are also standing firm
they've got five main demands one of
them was to withdraw the extradition
bill that happened in September but they
also want Hong Kong's authorities to
start a formal investigation into police
violence to release hundreds of arrested
protesters for the police to stop
labeling the protests as riots and they
want universal suffrage as in the
freedom to elect all of Hong Kong's
lawmakers plus the chief executive
others are calling for something more
radical full independence from China and
that's a red line for Beijing in fact
China's President Xi Jingping has openly
said those who engage in separatist
activities in any part of China will be
smashed into pieces China's state media
even released videos of Chinese troops
on the other side of the border in case
of a request from Hong Kong's leaders to
intervene
[Music]
but Hongkongers weren't swayed and not
only did they remain in the streets they
sent Beijing a message from the polls
recent local elections saw a record
number of people vote and the
pro-democracy camp made big gains they
now control 17 out of 18 councils before
the election the pro-beijing camp had
all 18 district council election is
already that the facto referendum to
prove how Hong people it is a free
election 47 so the anxiety is preparing
a lot of the youngsters leaders as
things stand it's really just a
countdown to the year 2040 7 some in
hong kong seri unification with china as
something inevitable but others aren't
clearly not going to give up Hong Kong's
autonomy without putting up a real fight
[Music]
there's a news story or a topic you want
to get your head around send us your
ideas get in touch with us on Twitter or
Facebook also make sure to LIKE Al
Jazeera's Facebook page and subscribe to
our YouTube channel so you can't miss
our next episode
[Music]